look at these images now tell me which
Obama here Israel to help families
refinance their homes to invest in
things like high-tech manufacturing
clean energy and the infrastructure that
creates good new jobs anyone the answer
is none of them none of these is
actually real so let me tell you how we
got here my inspiration for this work
was a project meant to preserve our last
chance for learning about Holocaust from
the survivors it's called new dimensions
in testimony and it allows you to have
interactive conversations with a
hologram of a real Holocaust survivor
how did you survive the Holocaust how
did I survive I survived what I believe
because Providence watched over me
turns out these answers were pre
recorded in a studio yet the effect is
astounding you feel so connected to his
story and to him as a person I think
there's something special about human
interaction that makes it much more
profound and personal than what books or
lectures or movies could ever teach us
so I saw this and began to wonder can we
create a model like this for anyone a
model that looks talks and acts just
like them so I set out to see if this
could be done and eventually came up
with the new solution the computer model
of a person using nothing but these
existing photos and videos of a person
if you can leverage this kind of passive
information just photos and videos that
are out there that's the key to scaling
to anyone by the way here's Richard
Feynman who in addition to being a Nobel
Prize winner in physics was also known
as a legendary teacher would it be great
if we could bring him back to give his
lectures and inspiring millions of kids
perhaps not just in English but in any
language
or if you could ask our grandparents for
advice and hear those comforting words
even if they're no longer with us or
maybe using this tool book authors alive
or not could read aloud all of their
books for anyone interested the query
possibilities here are endless and to me
that's very exciting and here's how it's
working so far first we introduce a new
technique that can reconstruct high
detail 3d face model from any image
without ever 3d scanning the person and
here's the same output model from
different views this also works on
videos by running the same algorithm on
each video frame and generate a moving
3d model and here's the same output
model from different angles turns out
this problem is very challenging but the
key trick is that we're going to analyze
a large photo collection of the person
beforehand for George W Bush we can just
search on Google and from that we're
able to be in an average model and
easier to refine the model to recover
the expression and find details like
creases and wrinkles what's fascinating
about this is that the photo collection
can come from your typical photos it
doesn't really matter what expression
you're making or where you took those
photos what matters is that there are a
lot of them and we're still missing
color here so next we develop a new
blending technique that improves upon a
simple averaging method and produces
sharp facial textures and colors and
this can be done for any expression now
we have a controllable model of a person
and the way it's control now is by a
sequence of static photos notice how the
wrinkles come and go depending on the
expression we can also use the video to
drive the model Rory but um somehow
we've managed to attract with another
some more amazing people and here's a
lot of fun demo so what you see here are
a controllable model of people IP from
their internet photos now if you
transfer the emotion from the input
video we can actually drive the entire
party it's a very difficult bill to pass
because there's a lot of moving parts
and
the legislative process is gonna be ugly
and so coming back a little bit else you
may go rather is to capture their
mannerisms or the unique way each of
these people talks and smile so to do
that can we actually teach the computer
to imitate the way someone talks by only
showing it video footage of the person
and what I did exactly was I let a
computer watch 14 hours of pure Barack
Obama given addresses and here's what we
can produce given only his audio the
results are clear America's businesses
have created 14.5 million new jobs over
75 straight months so what's being
synthesized here is only the mouth
region and here's how we do it our
pipeline uses a neural network to
convert an input audio into these mouth
points we get it through our job or
through Medicare or Medicaid then we
synthesize the texture enhanced details
in teeth and blend it into the head and
background from a source video women can
get free checkups and you can't get
charged more just for being a woman
young people can stay on a parent's plan
until they turn 26
I think these results seem very
realistic and intriguing but at the same
time frightening even to me our goal is
to build an accurate model of a person
not to misrepresent them but one thing
that concerns me is its potential for
misuse people been thinking about this
problem for a long time since the days
when fellowship first hit the market as
a researcher I'm also working on
countermeasure technology and I'm part
of an ongoing effort that AI Foundation
which uses a combination of machine
learning and human moderators to detect
fake images and videos fighting against
my own work and one of the tools we plan
to release is call reality defender
which is a web browser plug-in that can
flag potentially fake contents
automatically right in the browser
despite all this though fake videos
could do a lot of damage even before
anyone has a chance to verify so it's
very important that we make everyone
aware of what's currently possible so we
can have the right assumption and be
critical about what we see there's still
a long way to go before we can truly
model individual people and before we
can ensure the safety of this technology
but I'm excited and hopeful because if
we use it right and carefully this tool
can allow any individuals positive
impact on the world to be massively
scaled and really help shape our future
the way we want it to be thank you
[Applause]
[Music]